When you're creating
apps like Email Clients,
there will be times when there
are many emails that have arrived.
On a handheld,
you will be shown a notification that
looks like this using inbox style.
When you touch the notification,
it will open up on the Email Client and
show you all the emails.
On a wearable, you would like to see
more information about the emails
without having to pull
out the handheld device.
It's possible to create a series of
notifications, one for each email and
then stack will group them together.
The notifications are initially
shown as a single card.
That can be expanded into
multiple cards by touching it.
So here we create
a separate notification for
each email our app knows about.
You can see that we add the sender here
and the subject here for each email.
Now, we use the setGroup method to
specify a unique key for this group.
So Android Wear knows which
notifications should be
stacked together.
We then issue this like
any other notification.
And here is another notification for
a second email.
You'll notice the use of setGroup here,
just like the previous one.
And we issue this notification
in the same way as well.
The final step is to create
the notification for
the phone like it's shown here.
Clearly we don't want the individual
emails to each get a notification on
the handheld device.
This code sample creates the inbox
style shown in the previous image.
It adds a summary of all the emails
in a nice format that's perfect for
showing on a handheld device.
The interesting part is the code is
setGroup here, and setGroupSummary here.
This makes the notification
part of the previous group, but
we've specified that this is the summary
of the group by passing true here.
Summary is shown on the phone while
the other group items are shown
on the Android Wear device.